now that we're all so super excited that
russell t davies is coming back allow me
to um
throw a wet blanket on the enthusiasm
just a little bit
[Music]
[Music]
hey folks so when i did my video talking
about the return of russell t davies as
the showrunner for doctor who
i actually mentioned in it that while
i'm excited i'm very interested to see
what he'll do
he wasn't perfect in his original run as
show runner and i
said somewhat offhandedly that i could
do a whole video on the issues i have
with his tenure and enough people
expressed an interest in me doing that
that yeah
here we are before i get into this
there's a couple things i want to be
really clear about one despite the joke
i made in the intro i'm actually not
trying to dampen anybody's enthusiasm
i'm not trying to tear down russell t
davies i've actually done another video
where i talked with crispy pro arguing
that
rtd was better than moffitt as a
showrunner so check that out if you
doubt me on that and in addition to that
i actually don't have any sufficient
reason to believe that the issues i'm
about to outline are going to repeat
when he takes over again
again i mentioned in that video
previously that he has changed enough as
an artist that i don't think he's going
to approach it in the exact same way
with the exact same mindset that he did
before
so uh the one other thing that i'll
mention is some of the things i'm going
to talk about are not unique to him
actually a fair number of them were
continued through moffett's era so don't
bother pointing that out i'm well aware
this is not about how moffit is better
this is just looking at rtd's run
in a bubble by itself
and talking about some of the problems
that i had with it okay
okay
all right well i suppose we should start
with kind of the elephant in the room
which would be
the camp now it should be pointed out
doctor who has always been relatively
campy to some degree often just by
virtue of its production budget back in
the classic era the thing is rtd did
kind of lean into that a bit more
intentionally in a way that for me
personally i didn't love however i'm
putting this one at the front
because i actually don't want to dwell
on it that much while there was more
campy elements to his tenure than in say
moffatt or honestly even chibnall i do
feel that he tapered off of those the
first series is the one that has the
most blatant camp elements and i felt
like it actually got better balanced
during his time
they were pretty heavy in that first
series though which is actually why when
i did a video a couple years ago talking
about where to start newcomers to the
show i actually don't recommend starting
with rose and with series one because i
feel it's not particularly
representative of a lot of what the show
became since even under rtd's own tenure
so while i don't love a lot of the camp
elements in this
i am prepared to move on from that
because it seemed like even rtd realized
eh maybe we don't need as much as we
started out with but i think it probably
would have been brought up in the
comments if i didn't mention it so uh
let's move on next up i want to talk
about the mystery box format which
again is not unique to his era actually
most
series of doctor who have this two
varying degrees how intrusive i feel it
is is
goes up and down from series to series
but every single one of rtd's series had
it now when i say mystery box i need to
be really clear about this because
people misconstrue this a lot they seem
to think that i have a problem with
there being a series overall story or an
arc or some sort of thing cooking in the
background of doctor who at all and that
i wanted purely episodic that's not what
i'm saying but what i'm saying is there
are other ways to do it besides what
rtd did every single series which is to
take one thing and just keep dropping
and sprinkling it across the show
and not have it pay off until the finale
in series one it was bad wolf series two
was torchwood what about torchwood i
know i'm not supposed to know about it i
realize that not even the united nations
knows series three it was mr saxon
[Music]
and then in series four
it was the planets vanishing what do you
mean lost how'd you lose a planet i
would say series 4 is the least
intrusive of those the other ones feel
incredibly crowbared in and just shoved
in there to remind you hey this is the
thing we'll explain it eventually the
reason i don't like the mystery box
format is that it's not actually
stringing you along with the story like
oh where's that going it's literally
just dropping something that has little
to no meaning until they explain it
that
doesn't
really engage me it annoys me because
i'm just like yeah okay yeah i know
you'll get back to that but right now it
means nothing so up until they get to
the final part where they explain what
that is all about or show where it was
going i just i don't care like i said
the uh the planets disappearing was the
least intrusive because when it came up
it actually mattered to the plot as
opposed to all the vote sacks and stuff
for all the bad wolf stuff which only
mattered in retrospect by the time he
got to the end now again i'm not saying
that you can't make a mystery box format
work what bothered me about this was the
fact that he did it every
single
time
and arguably did it with the specials as
well because he introduced the four knox
thing in the second of those he will
knock
four times
it's it's just a format that i feel is
been way overused and as i said
continued after rtd left so i'm well
well sick of that but even at the time
that he moved on and moffat took over i
was already done with it i don't think
it's a particularly
clever or engaging way to string along
an overarching story for the series and
the fact that he did it every time
that bugs me
the next couple are going to circle
around the companions uh the first one
is a bit superficial
the latter one not so much the latter
one actually
frustrates me a bit more but uh
superficially
uh i really don't like that he contrived
reasons for the doctor to kiss the
companions
every single
series
with every companion
because you know with eccleston he had
to kiss rose to take the
the energy from the tardis from her
which like i understand that they
rationalized it as being something other
than a romantic kiss but it still felt
weird because
while she definitely had a romantic
thing going with tennant i never got
that vibe from her and eccleston
personally so that was weird then when
we introduce martha we have the whole
kissing to make her read is not human
briefly and so we contrive it there and
then with donna it's played for the
biggest comedy thing where she kisses
him as a shock thing and like i get that
you're lampshading it but you're still
just doing it and overall the
romanticizing of the doctor in general
and the relationship with the companion
in specific
that frustrates me and what i say
romanticizing i don't necessarily mean
in terms of having an unrequited or a
requited love interest because obviously
that doesn't apply to donna but she
still gets this
romanticized thought of what their
relationship is insofar as the way she
envisions them being together and
traveling forever platonically yes but
that is still a romanticized idea of
what their future will be together even
if it doesn't involve the standard
definition of romance and this entire
dynamic with the companions is something
that was interesting when first
introduced because it was new this
hadn't really gone on in the classic
series arguably maybe a little with
romana but that was
actually largely just uh spill over
chemistry between two performers who
were dating
for a while so
this was new elements but the fact that
it kind of became the default
for the companions and yes again
continued on even after rtd left but
again it's the fact that he did it to
some degree every single time but that
factors into my bigger
issue with how he handled the companions
he decided that nobody would ever leave
the tardis
under
anything other than
traumatic or broken circumstances
the only way rose was ever going to
leave was if she was separated by a
dimensional wall
the only way that donna was ever going
to leave
is if it was literally going to kill her
to stay and even then she didn't want to
go the doctor had to force her to
now martha did leave on her own but it's
still treated as a
traumatic thing it's not her going this
has been fun we've had a good time but
i'm ready to stop now it's treated as a
breakup it's treated as her saying look
this is bad for me and so it's still
treated as something more traumatic then
companions
would just leave
in the old series they would just leave
and like again granted the first time
you explore it this way is interesting
because
only a handful of the departures for
companions were in any way traumatic for
anybody back in the classic series so it
wasn't something that was explored all
that much
but again
i feel like it's a it was at the time a
bit of self-projection on rtd's part he
seemed to come at it from an angle of
well
if i was with the doctor i would never
want to stop stop traveling so
all the characters that he made
also have that same thought process oh i
never want this to stop well if they
never wanted to stop the only way we can
make it stop is by doing something
traumatic to them whether it be
separating them with dimension walls
whether it be wiping their memory or
whether it be traumatizing them with a
year of wandering the planet while their
family's tortured
so
the fact that we can't just have an
amenable it's been good doctor thank you
departure under his tenure that
that
combined with the romanticization wit of
the relationship between the companion
and the doctor
again as a one-off i could get it but as
an overall trend don't like it i mean
that's kind of the thing overall with
the things that i'm bringing up they
have worked at some point usually the
first time that he did them but then he
just kept doing them and that was one of
the reasons that i was actually really
okay with the time that he left because
i felt like he hadn't been able to break
out of certain patterns in the way he
was approaching the story at the time
back then again to reiterate that
doesn't mean i think he's going to do
those patterns again we'll see and also
tied to the companions is
a spotlight being thrown on the domestic
life of the companion now again
when the series started this was
uncharted territory because prior to
this point companions basically got on
board the tardis traveled for a while
and then eventually left we didn't
really address where they came from what
they left behind what their relationship
with people back home was
so it was fertile territory to do
something new
with rose and have a boyfriend back home
to have her mother who cares about her
back home and to try and juggle all of
that while traveling with the doctor it
was new at the time
but that newness doesn't stick and while
this same pattern of of highlighting the
domestic life of the companion would
eventually get us wealth and wilf is
amazing and perfect and awesome
there isn't all that much brought to the
table by donna's mother and can you tell
me anything actually contributed to the
overall plot
by martha's family
i know they get a chunk of screen time
especially on the back end but
does it add anything that isn't already
there
because i don't think it does
it started to become an obligation like
well we addressed once that the
companion's home life is somehow
affected so now we have to address it
every time but you don't
there's also a practical fallout from
that which is that if you establish and
start dealing with the fact that these
characters have a home life back on
earth
that means the story has to keep
coming
back to modern day earth which is
another thing that just annoys me about
the modern era in general now again not
strictly speaking unique to davies and
i'm not even sure he was the biggest
offender of this
but it did give a reason for
the character and the show to just be
rooted in modern day earth as a default
and all the space travel was you know it
was treated as that as a trip the home
isn't the tardis the home is you know
with your family back home and this and
the tardis is just your means of
traveling again to pull on the classic
series the tardis was home
during the time that these people
traveled and it meant that the show
actually
after we got past the third doctor did
not come back to earth
all that often
because
why would you you could go anywhere in
time and space why would you keep coming
back to earth now i don't doubt that
part of the reason to have more stories
set in modern day earth was a budget
control issue because you can just do
location shooting as opposed to having
to build sets or trying cgi
alien worlds or whatever so like i get
it i understand there were probably
logistical considerations to this
decision but it still makes the doctor
and the doctors travels less
otherworldly because we have to keep
coming back
because we brought up the domestic life
of the companions so if you're gonna
bring it up you gotta do something with
it so you just
keep
coming
back
and like minor tangent how much you
wanna bet if we ever get the thing that
i want which is to get a companion not
from modern day from either the future
or the past or an alien world or
something
how much you want to bet that we won't
keep going back to where they come from
all the dang time
modern day earth is is
i'm not going to say yields no good
stories there are some very good stories
set on modern day earth in doctor who in
the modern era but
it is by default kind of the most boring
place to set a story and you have to do
a bunch of other stuff to make it
interesting which sometimes the show
does but you're starting at a
disadvantage doing that and lastly this
one is probably more subjective than any
of these and like again if you enjoy any
of the aspects that i liked and missed
them when he was gone or liked that they
were continued when he was gone that's
fine this is ultimately my opinion
and this last one is uh the most sort of
my opinion than the others and probably
the one i'm most likely to get called
out on but i'm gonna bring it up anyway
he was kind of self-indulgent
and again that's not to say that other
creators weren't moffett
could get very self-indulgent but uh the
way that they would do it is kind of
reflective of their approach where
moffat would get self-indulgent by
basically
disappearing up his own
big brain
and trying to be super ultra clever
rtd would get self-indulgent in a bit of
a more traditional way and i think you
can look to the finales for that
in hindsight series one probably has the
most restrained finale
and that ends with the companion having
the power of a god bringing back uh jack
hardness and apparently at the time
wiping out all daleks including the
dalek emperor and then the doctor dying
like that's big and that's the most
restrained that it gets we get to series
two and we have the very
uh honestly fan fakie idea of daleks and
cybermen just
going at it and again like none of these
are bad ideas but i'm going over the
pattern with you then we get to series
three
we bring back the master
and we have this whole we just we
literally turned the doctrine to jesus i
mean not literally literally but
practically i forgive you
he is reborn through the power of belief
in him it's
really kind of self-indulgent in terms
of the character and then series four
and then ultimately the end of time part
two gets really self-indulgent on the
show as a whole in terms of well we
gotta bring everybody in that we
possibly can and we gotta have the
doctor go on this massive goodbye tour
stopping in on every companion that we
can get to come in for a day of shooting
and
again i get it it's kind of the return
of the king thing where this has been
going on so long if we're ending this
story or in the case of doctor who
ending the show runner and this doctor's
eras then yeah
we kind of earned the right to
have these extra things but again the
indulgence
escalated during his time
at times honestly to the detriment of
the story while there is
a superficial thrill at things like
daleks versus cybermen and so many uh
past characters coming back in journey's
end and then having the doctor stop by
and say goodbye to all these people
there is a little bit of a thrill to
that as strictly as a narrative function
it
drags it bloats
and that
as i said kind of got
worse as time went on
now
that's all i really have in terms of
broad things because what i didn't want
this to do was to pick out specific
episodes that he wrote and just go
through a whole list of nitpicks cause
you know what you can watch my uh
overdue doctor who reviews uh i'll try
and put a playlist up there if you want
to see me take those on one episode at a
time and bring up whatever my issues are
that's not what i wanted here i wanted
to talk about the broad strokes and the
repeated things that he did across his
arrow that
i didn't love
does it mean i don't like rtd no no it
doesn't doesn't mean i'm not excited for
him to come back no it absolutely does
not
but
i said i had issues nothing you asked
there you go
so
what do you think about my assessment
here uh even if you think i'm very wrong
please be polite about it but whatever
your thoughts are drop something down
the comments let's talk about it like
share and subscribe all the usual stuff
i got a patreon that is how i pay the
bills and i'm able to
talk to you folks on a regular basis so
maybe consider supporting me there
there's also youtube memberships if you
want to go that way but don't worry too
much about it
because uh at the end of the day
you are the council i'm just running the
meetings and until next time this
council
is adjourned
[Music]
this video wouldn't have been possible
without the support of my patrons and i
want to give special thanks to jared
boyce
mj the doctor tracy scrabbit vincent
paul bartolucci kailyn schwartz edelman
robin moore ross schultz and shayla
gorla
thanks so much
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
now
[Music]
foreign
[Music]